alors on vient d'avoir une audition
extrêmement intéressante conjointe avec
la commission des finances sur l'impact
des enjeux financiers sur les enjeux
sécuritaires et nous continuons ce ce
cycle euh en partageant cette fois notre
audition avec la section française de
l'Assemblée parlementaire de de la
Francophonie que préside améliia lacrafi
euh d'ailleurs vous aurez sans doute
accord madame la la présidente
d'expliquer au commissaire à la défense
le rôle de la section française au sein
de de l'APF et peut-être son délégué
général Bruno fou va nous rejoindra tout
à l'heure après donc les enjeux
d'endettement de coopération monétaire
que nous venons d'aborder avec la
commission des finances nous passons
maintenant aux enjeux aussi importants
des enjeux médiatique et culturel dans
la relation afrique-fance la diversité
de ces sujets témoine du caractère
pleinement multidimensionnel de notre
partenariat avec les États africains et
démontre la nécessité d'avancer dans
dans ce cycle avant qu'au sein de la
commission des finances nousous
replongions directement sur les enjeux
de sécurité madame Cécile méi euh
j'espère que je prononce bien votre nom
vous êtes directrice des stratégies et
coopération internationale transverse de
France medéia monde je pense que tout le
monde le sait mais France medéia monde
regroupe notamment la chaîne
d'information continue France24 et la et
la radio mondiale RFI vous pourrez
certainement revenir sur les enjeux
relatif à l'image des médias français
sur le continent leur audience et leur
portée réelle alors où les réseaux
sociaux sont omniprésents mais également
sur la contribution de ces médias au
rayonnement de la francophonie nous
serions également intéressés de vous
entendre sur le rôle que peut jouer
l'audiovisuel extérieur de la France
dans notre relation avec Les Afriques
alors alors que certaines voies
s'élèvent pour en faire un outil
d'influence à partentière c'est aussi
une question parfois nous pose les
Africains ils nous disent mais France 24
alors est-ce que c'est une chaîne dont
la ligne éditoriale est totalement libre
ou est-ce que c'est une chaîne au
service des intérêts français vous
pourriez peut-être revenir à ce titre
sur le lancement des états généraux de
l'information souhaités par le Président
de la République Monsieur Emmanuel Casar
rou j'espère bien prononcer votre nom
vous êtes président du musée kbranly
Jacques Chirac nous nous serions heureux
d'entendre votre analyse sur la
perception de l'action culturelle en
Afrique alors que d'autres pays
développent des stratégies parfois plus
visibles je pense notamment à la Chine
qui multiplie l'ouverture d'institut
d'institut confusus vous pourriez
notamment revenir sur les enjeux
entourant la restitution d'œuvre et la
coopération entre les musées français et
africains mais également avec les
représentants des diasporas en France
madame la Présidente je vous cède la
parole Messieurs les Présidents Madame
la Directrice mes chers collègues c'est
à ma connaissance la première fois qu'un
délégué de la section française et
certainement un président délégué pardon
certainement une présidente déléguée
copréside une réunion commune avec une
commission permanente de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est pourquoi je tiens à
remercier très chaleureusement mon
collègue Thomas gassilou d'avoir
l'honneur de d'être à ses côtés avec la
commission défense je veux également
saluer son initiative visant à associer
les membres de la section française à
l'Assemblée parlementaire de l'Assemblée
parlementaire la francophonie aux
travaux qu'il mène dans le cadre d'un
cycle d'information sur les relation
entre la France et le continent africain
à cet égard je souhaite rappeler que si
l'Assemblée parlementaire de la
Francophonie réunit à ce jour 92
sections membres associé ou observateur
la section française y occupe une place
toute particulière pour plusieurs
raisons elle est en effet la plus
nombreuse avec 90 députés et 60
sénateurs et sénatrices le Parlement
français est aussi le deè le plus gros
contributeur financier de l'APF après
l'Organisation internationale de la
Francophonie l'OIF de même plusieurs
parlementaires français occupent des
fonctions importantes au sein des
différents organes de la PF je veux ici
saluer le travail de notre collègue
Bruno fou qui a été désigné délégué
général de la PF et anime cette
institution au côté du député canadien
Francis Drouin qui la préside plusieurs
de nos collègues députés et sénateurs
sont également soit présidents de
commission et de réseau soit rapporteur
au sein de ces mêmes organes je suis
moi-même l'une des vice-présidentes de
la PF vous le voyez la section française
s'implique fortement dans le
fonctionnement et l'animation de la PF
et met un point d'honneur à être
représenté et intervenir à chaque
réunion d'instance la position française
portée par les élus français est
toujours attendue et écoutée pour autant
l'APF ce n'est pas la section française
l'APF n'est pas un outil au service du
Parlement français les parlementaires
membres de la section française ont à
cœur de concilier leur double statut de
membre de laapf et membrees du Parlement
français c'est pourquoi je considère
comme très important les échanges que
nous aurons ce matin et je veux
remercier très chaleureusement Monsieur
Emmanuel casreou et Madame Cécile mi
pour les éclairages qu'ils pourront nous
apporter la relation entre la France et
le continent africain est marquée par la
confusion d'une histoire pesante pour
reprendre les termes utilisés par
Jean-Louis borlot comprenant tr trois
périodes la colonisation la
décolonisation et la mondialisation de
l'Afrique qui se tourne aujourd'hui vers
d'autres partenaires nous en avons
largement parlé hier en séance publique
lors des débats sur les partenariats
renouvelés entre la France et les pays
africains face à cette Afrique nouvelle
la France s'est longtemps interrogée à
engagé des actions très fortes dans ce
sens dont la restitution des biens
culturels et bien d'autres actions que
je ne pourrais pas vous lister
aujourd'hui le président la République
l'a dit le 23 février lors de son
dernier déplacement en Afrique centrale
nous avons un destin lié avec le
continent africain et nous devons
choisir quel rapport nous voulons
entretenir avec les pays africains en
sortant des grilles de lecture du passé
il nous faut considérer les pays
africains comme des partenaires avec qui
nous avons des intérêts et des
responsabilités partagées c'est un
continent où nous devons bâtir des
relations respectueuses équilibrées et
responsables pour lutter ensemble pour
des causes commune comme la lutte contre
le changement climatique c'est une
nouvelle réalité que nous ne pouvons pas
nier et s'incarne dans cette nouvelle
politique de partenariat que nous menons
désormais il est très intéressant pour
nous de vous entendre tant les champs
culturels et médiatiques sont importants
pour ces relations renouvelées que la
France entend bâtir avec l'Afrique
l'importance de nos relations
culturelles avec les pays africains est
évidente nous en avons eu la preuve lors
de l'organisation de la session africain
2020 je la constate sur le terrain à
avec la programmation de nos instituts
français ou de nos alliances françaises
partout en Afrique elle est sans doute
appelée à s'accroître avec le projet de
la Maison des mondes africains ou même
la cité de la langue française à viler
cotray qui fera la parabelle en tout cas
je l'espère à des projets communs avec
les pays d'Afrique la question du relais
de l'information et des médias en langue
française au travers de médias France
méiaamonde et de TV5 Monde est également
un enjeu politique de taille comme nous
l'avons vu avec avec l'interdiction de
France24 ou RFI dans certains pays du
Sahel sans doute allez-vous nous donner
quelques pistes pour établir cette
nouvelle relation par le dialogue et
l'échange par le croisement des savoirs
et des expériences que nous partageons
déjà à l'APF et dans l'espace
francophone je vous remercie pour votre
attention merci madame la Présidente et
Madame mégie vous avez désormais la
parole pour une durée d'environ 10
minutes alors j'appuie sur ce bouton qui
doit être le bon merci merci beaucoup
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la Présidente délégué mesdames et
messieurs merci d'être d'être là ce
matin euh je suis effectivement
directrice des stratégies et coopération
éditoriale et non pas internationale
mais ça peut se ressembler transverse à
France médiamonde et j'ai l'honneur de
de représenter Marie-Christine Saragosse
la PDG du groupe qui s'excuse de ne pas
être là et qui est en déplacement à
partir d'aujourd'hui en en Roumanie
alors voilà euh pour pour ce propos
liminaire je me permets quand même de de
rappeler quelques points concernant
notre groupe France méia monde le groupe
de l'Audiovisuel Extérieur de la France
ce sont trois médias RFI la radio
d'actualité mondiale en français et en
16 autres langues FRANCE 24 vous l'avez
rappelé la chaîne d'information
internationale enue en français en
anglais en arabe et en espagnol et Monte
Carlo dualia la radio française en
langue arabe diffusée au Proche et au
Moyen Orient donc qui ne concerne pas
directement le le le continent africain
mais qui est une part importante de
notre dispos positif de l'Audiovisuel
Extérieur de la France nos trois médias
ont compté en 2022 près de 260 millions
d'auditeurs téléspectateurs et
d'internautes chaque semaine à travers
le monde l'Afrique est historiquement
notre premier bassin d'audience c'est
donc un continent majeur pour pour nos
médias le propos que que je vais
développer devant vous va s'articuler
autour de deux grands points un ancrage
historique de nos médias en Afrique mais
qui évolue aujourd'hui et vous en avez
déjà déjà parl dans dans les différentes
auditions dans un contexte de grande
tension et de tension accrue et dans un
second temps une stratégie que nous
développons aujourd'hui qui est la
stratégie de proximité nous l'avons mise
en œuvre déjà depuis plusieurs années
auprès des publics du continent africain
et que nous entendons encore renforcer
dans les années à venir alors RFI et
France24 sont des médias référents pour
couvrir l'actualité du continent
africain l'expertise de nos journalistes
à Paris un service dédié à RFI le
service Afrique des journalistes
spécialisés à France24 mais référent
également par une grande présence sur le
terrain sur le continent un très
important réseau de de correspondant de
près d'une centaine de correspondants
sur l'ensemble du continent des envoyés
spéciaux permanents à Abidjan à Dakar et
à Nairobi donc Les Afriques autant
l'Afrique de l'Ouest que l'Afrique de
l'Est sont concernés par la présence de
ces professionnels de RFI et des
rédactions tion délocalisé j'y
reviendrai un petit peu plus tard qui
sont installé sur le continent avec des
professionnels venus du continent
africain nos médias proposent
quotidiennement une couverture de
l'actualité africaine tant dans les
programmes d'information qu'à travers
les émissions référent les les sessions
d'actualité midi soir matin et nuit sur
RFI deux journaux dédié à l'Afrique sur
France24 où nous donnons un écho mondial
à tout ce qui fait événement en Afrique
en offrant également une image positive
et fédératrice du continent à travers
notamment des événements comme celui du
mois de janvier prochain qui est la
Coupe d'Afrique des nations où nous
prévoyons un un très important
dispositif ce qui fait notre succès
auprès des publics du continent africain
c'est aussi la très forte interaction
avec ces publics la place à
l'interactivité à la proximité est
présente dans nos nos programmes un des
programmes phar de de Radio France
Internationale et sans doute appel sur
l'actualité une émission quotidienne de
matinée où les auditeurs interviennent
posent des questions et les rédactions
de RFI où les experts leur répondent un
magazine dédié à la jeunesse qui est
hebdomadaire qui s'appelle alor alors on
dit quoi qui là aussi traite des sujets
qui qui concernent le quotidien de notre
auditoire avec des des appels très
nombreux d'auditeurs là encore et puis
un dernier point qui sont les
délocalisations c'est-à-dire nous nous
en non nos équipes sur le continent et
là il est toujours extrêmement
impressionnant de mesurer la la
notoriété des journalistes et des
animateurs de de RFI et de France24 lors
de ces déplacements par ailleurs comme
le prévoi les missions de France
médamonde les missions de nos médias de
de service public de société nationale
de programme nous donnons un très large
écho à l'actualité française dans toute
sa diversité dans toutes ses dimensions
le lien est indéniable à travers cette
actualité il est souligné avec avec le
continent africain vous parliez madame
de la saison Africa 2020 qui avait été
aussi qui avait été notamment un moment
phare de de notre couverture et qui à
travers les la présence des diasporas et
des échanges réguliers entre des
échanges humains réguliers entre la
France et l'Afrique nourrissent nos
programmes en matière de distribution de
diffusion nous bénéficions d'une
présence extrêmement importante sur le
continent africain en radio RFI a le
plus grand parc FM avec 100 15 émetteurs
elle est reprise par près de 500 radios
partenaires à travers le continent ces
radios partenaires ce sont des radios
locales qui reprennent une grande partie
de nos programmes et notamment nos
programmes d'information on a aussi
gardé une diffusion en onde courte et on
le verra quand on parlera de ces pays où
nous sommes notamment coupés en FM que
les ones courtes ont une vraie
importance dans cette région du monde et
ce qui permet de toucher notamment des
populations plus isolées des des grandes
villes et singulièrement dans la dans
dans la bande sahélienne en télévision
France 24 est diffusé sur le satellite
et sur la TNT quand cela est possible
dans certains pays et dans les zones
urbaines au total ce sont 62 millions de
foyers qui sont distribués par par
France 24 sur le continent africain et
puis bien sûr le numérique nos sites
propres RFI France24 dans leurs
différentes déclinaisons mais également
les différentes plateformes les réseaux
sociaux la syndication avec des sites
panafri et depuis ce mois d'octobre nous
avons lancé des chaînes WhatsApp qui est
un nouveau vecteur de diffusion
d'information pour nos médias et
certaines de nos émissions et nous
enregistrons j'y reviendrai tout à
l'heure des performances record en la
matière donc nos médias sont très
puissants ils enregistrent des résultats
d'audience exceptionnel la dernière
étude Africas scope menée par l'institut
Cantard nous montre que près de 60 % de
la population en Afrique francophone 60
% de la population en Afrique Fran
francophone suit RFI et ou France24 de
façon hebdomadaire RFI est la première
radio internationale en Afrique
francophone elle est toujours classée
dans le top 5 des radios les plus écouté
quotidiennement dans les SEP villes
couvertes par cette étude et France 24
conforte son statut de première chaîne
d'information internationale toute cible
confondu sur sur l'Afrique francophone
elle figure parmi les 10 chaînes les
plus regardées chaque semaine le
contexte vous le vous le disiez dans vos
propos liminires le contexte sur le
continent africain évolue change et
marqué ces dernières années par un
contexte de grande tension auxquel nous
devons faire face très concrètement cela
se manifeste par une recrudescence des
manipulations de l'information de la
désinformation des infox comme on dit en
bonne francophonie on peut considérer
qu'il y a des tentatives de
déstabilisation directement
instrumentalisé à travers c'est C ces
manipulations de l'info et la la
désinformation instrumentalisé par
certains états de deux faits nous
semblent importants à noter le lancement
de chaînne à destination de l'Afrique
par la Turquie qui propose et assume une
verion
alternative de l'actualité du monde
alternative à la vision occidentale
c'est revendiqué par la Turquie qui qui
lance cette chaîne à destination de
l'Afrique et puis la présence d'une
offre francophone du média russe Russia
Today avec l'installation d'un bureau à
Alger de manière à couvrir l'ensemble du
continent africain et singulièrement de
l'Afrique francophone des médias qui
nourrissent des narratifs anti-français
c'est assumé également par par ceux qui
les dirigent et qui donc attaquent la
France et nourrissent également à
travers une diffusion et une
dissémination de ces
contenus-l au départ de façon très
virtuelle sur les réseaux réseaux
sociaux nourrissent aussi et pénètrent
progressivement au sein des opinions
publiques et se manifestent ensuite sur
le terrain parfois de façon très
violente nous sommes en première ligne
également à travers nos médias face aux
attaques contre la liberté d'informer
vous l'avez rappelé madame nos médias
ont fait l'objet de de coupure de
censure aujourd'hui dans trois pays
africains d'abord au Mali et au Burkina
Faso l'année dernière au Niger depuis le
mois d'août dernier suite à la prise du
pouvoir par des mouvements pchistes et
là l'ensemble de nos médias y compris
les diffusions par les radios
partenaires par exemple de RFI sont
soumis à la censure et ont été coupés si
nous sommes coupés c'est d'abord parce
que nous sommes puissants nous sommes
les premières chaînes coupées dans ces
pays-là quand il s'agit pour les
pouvoirs qui ont enfin pour les
mouvements pchistes qui ont pris le
pouvoir de de de resserrer la liberté de
l'information mais aussi parce que nous
apportons une information libre et
indépendante qui parfois et même souvent
dans ces situations là dérange plus
généralement il nous semble que dans ces
circonstances nous sommes également
coupés parce que nous sommes certes
français mais aussi des médias
internationaux et ces censures sont
généralement les signes d'une très forte
dégradation de la liberté de la presse
et du droit d'informer dans ces pays-là
dont font les frais très rapidement et
très lourdement les journalistes et les
les médias locaux du
continent malgré les coupures nous
restons extrêmement suivis les
stratégies de contournement sont mises
en place et nous nous arrivons à voir à
travers nos antennes que des publics
continuent au Mali à nous suivre par
exemple sur YouTube à appeler nos
émissions interactives c'est un exemple
parmi d'autres mais nos chaînes WhatsApp
je vous en parlais tout à l'heure en un
temps record quelques semaines seulement
près d'un million d'abonnés pour la
chaîne WhatsApp consacrée à l'émission
appel sur l'actualité pour RFI et 1004
aujourd'hui pour la chaîne de France24
en français donc ce sont des des moyens
de contournement qui reçoivent euh un
public extrêmement nombreux et qui
montre combien nos médias sont aussi
attendus euh les coupures néanmoins nous
font perdre près de 7 millions de
téléspectateurs uniquement dans les
trois pays de téléspectateurs et
d'auditeurs bien sûr dans les trois pays
que sont le Mali le Burkina Faso et euh
le Niger je passe rapidement mais il est
évident que ces situations de grande
tension euh voire de confrontation nous
font courir euh font courir des risques
sécuritaires majeurs à nos équipes nos
correspondants ne peuvent plus et nos
envoyés spéciaux ne peuvent plus aller
dans ces sur ces terrain-là et les
correspondants qui doivent y rester euh
sont évidemment suivis de d'extrêmement
près et de façon très régulière par
notre dispositif de de sécurité nous
continuons malgré tout à faire notre
travail d'un journalisme indépendant
libre qui lutte contre les infox mais
nous ne sommes pas naïfs qui lutte
contre la désinformation sans naïveté
nous restons attachés à nos valeurs et
nous poursuivons notre action à des
destination des publices africains avec
comme ligne vous vous avez évoqué ce mot
comme ligne d'action des partenariat
pour les publics africains et avec les
les professionnels du continent africain
donc à ce titre nous avons trois
rédactions qui sont délocalisées sur le
continent africain une à Dakar la
dernière en date pour y diffuser et y
produire et y diffuser des contenus en
langue régional le mandincamp et le F F
sont opérés depuis Dakar laousa et le
soelli sont opérés depuis l'egos depuis
2007 et Nairobi depuis 2010 et ça pour
nous ce sont des ancrages et des
stratégies qui qui doivent nous
permettre d'être en en plus grande
proximité c'est un mot essentiel pour
nous c'est le le le développement à
venir de notre notre politique de de
production et de diffusion vers le
continent africain dans des langues
transnationales de façon à pouvoir
servir des publics le plus largement
possible et ne pas rester enfermé dans
cette dans cette dans un dialogue qui
serait totalement déséquilibré où on
considérerait que nos médias émettent de
Paris vers des publics qui entendent un
message venu de beaucoup trop loin enfin
dernière chose est évidemment
essentielle la lutte contre la
désinformation contre la manipulation de
l'information nous avons en tête de de
d'augmenter bien évidemment nos
productions en ce domaine nous
organisons en réseau notre production de
lutte contre les infox ce que l'on
appelle le débunkage de façon à ce que
l'ensemble des des différentes
rédactions de RFI se nourrisse et puisse
diffuser et avoir un impact encore plus
large dans dans ce domaine auprès des
des publics et mettre en valeur le
travail de de nos équipe et nous avons
deux projets essentiels et structurants
qui ont été portés par Marie-Christine
Saragosse dans son son projet
présidentielle 100 % numérique une offre
100 % numérique panafricaine à
destination des jeunes
public africain et un décrochage en
télévision pour France24 qui serait
opéré depuis Dakar où l'offre
d'information professionnelle devenue
depuis et vers l'Afrique francophone
serait encore plus valorisé merci de
votre attention merci Madame la
Directrice la parole est désormais à
Monsieur kazarou président du musée
kbranli Jacques cherac monsieur le
Président Madame la
laprésidente monsieur président madame
la coprésidente merci merci de de me
recevoir alors
ma ma ma contribution est beaucoup plus
modeste évidemment puisque le musée du
kbranli a dans son dans ses missions la
préservation l'étude la valorisation des
cultures des quatre continents en dehors
de l'Europe l'Afrique est donc une
partie de notre de notre perspective de
nos missions pour vous donner une idée
nous avons nous conservons
370000 œuvres qui remontent certaines à
400 ans elles sont en France depuis très
longtemps euh et les collections
africaines représentent 80 90000 œuvres
euh nous conservons également plusieurs
millions de documents photos et
documents et archives que nous nous
employons à à à à
enrichir notre présence et notre action
en direction du du du du continent
africain est assez ancienne puisque
effectivement nous nous partageons cette
histoire commune cette histoire qui est
parfois complexe à à analyser cette
histoire quelquefois que l'on découvre
nous-même tant sur la partie de la
colonisation que la partie des des des
décolonisations je pense en particulier
avec le le Cameroun où on a découvert un
certain nombre de découverts je veux
dire que c'était pas dans le dans dans
dans les les les dans la la comment la
la la culture commune certaines ces
événements qui nous amènent aussi à
reconsidérer la manière dont nous
traitons une histoire une histoire plus
ancienne en gros nous nous travaillons
sur sur cinq sur cinq axes bien sûr avec
ce qui a fait finalement le le l'ADN de
de de ce musée c'est-à-dire la
transparence la transparence sur ses
collection la transparence sur ces
documents la transparence sur
l'information que le le le le que
l'établissement détient sur sur les
collections et sur le partage l'idée que
une
[Musique]
étude moderne et contemporaine de ces
collections ne peut se faire qu'avec un
double regard le regard à la fois depuis
depuis Paris depuis l'histoire de ces
élection la manière dont elles a été
constitué l'histoire aussi du regard
l'histoire du goût l'histoire de la de
de du rapport de la France aussi avec
ces différents espaces mais également la
perception que peuvent avoir nos
collègues nos nos contemporains
aujourd'hui de cette histoire de
l'appréciation qu'on peut avoir sur ces
objets depuis depuis le leur point de
vue nous avons donc mis en place une une
série de projets de recherche
scientifiqu sur nos collections avec ce
double regard nous bénéficions de ce de
pour se faire de de bourse du ministère
de de la culture qui nous permett de
faire venir nos collègues pour étudier
ensemble les collections en toute
transparence nous avons accueilli nous
avons travaillé avec le le Tchad avec le
musée national du Tchad donc il s'agit
toujours de de de de collègues qui
viennent et qui ont des responsabilités
au plus haut niveau dans les musées
nationaux qui concervent les collections
dans dans dans les pays qui nous
intéressent et qui sont intéressés
également par cette relation évidemment
tout ceci se fait j'ai oubliais de le
dire effectivement mais ça va de soit
dans le cadre de cette nouvelle offre de
relation entre la France et et et et les
pays d'Afrique qui était lancé à partir
du discours de de de agadouu et avec
cette proposition également de d'opérer
des restitutions et donc c'est dans ce
cadre aussi que que que vient ce ce ce
travail de d'ouverture ce travail de
partage ce travail d'analyse commune et
euh de euh de culture commune j'allais
dire sur la manière d'aborder les les
collections d'anciennes et les et les
différentes épisodes historiques qu' ont
traversé les pays on a donc travaillé
avec le musée national du du Tchad qui
avait une demande assez globale sur
l'ensemble de nos
collections la venue de notre collègue
pendant près de 2 mois à Paris pendant 3
mois à Paris en 2021 a permis de de lui
a permis de se rendre compte que ses
collections on été en en grande partie
impressionnante par le chiffre qui avait
été fusé mais que la qualité de ces
collections était pas forcément en
rapport avec ce ce cette impression
numérique et donc on a commencé un
travail très précis d'analyse des
différentes des différentes collections
sachant queune grande partie des
collections qui sont conservé à Paris
sont
aussi ont aussi une histoire commune
avec les collections qui sont les cœurs
des collections nationales que ça soit
au Tchad au Sénégal au Burkina Faso et
cetera donc il y a une histoire commune
aussi de la Constitution des collections
et donc ce qui cette ce travail commun
peut est mutuellement bénéfique on a
travaillé également avec le BurkinaFaso
avec un collègue qui est venu pendant un
mois avec le Mali avec un avec le le le
directeur du du musée national avec
lequel nous nous tentons de continuer
d'avoir des des des relations malgré les
les les les la difficulté on est
persuadé que ce sont ces relations
humaine et cette cette passion commune
en fait qui qui fait qui crée un un fil
cert fragile mais qui peut permettre de
passer une période de tension une
période de difficulté où on sent aussi
que certains de nos nos collègues
peuvent parfois être sujet de de
suspicion par leur rapport qu'ils
peuvent avoir avec nous on sent que
souvent il faut que nous prenions en
compte des des
difficultés temporaires dans certains
pays pour mettre un un ralenti sur la la
les les les l'envie que nous avons de de
de d'aller plus loin dans dans les
investigations et donc il y a des des
temps qui s'adaptent comme ça en
fonction de de de l'actualité c'est
c'est particulièrement vrai pour le pour
le Mali mais nous allons pouvoir renouer
ce partenariat ne serait-ce que par des
voies également de visioconférence avec
notre collègue du Mali afin de continuer
à faire ce travail très important sur
cette histoire commune complexe sur la
constitution des collections en
particulier en période
coloniale en travaillant avec ces
différents pays on s'est aperçu que il
il nous fallait quelque chose de de de
plus global et et et qui permett de de
travailler de manière multilatérale on a
besoin de de ce travail en bilatéral qui
nous permet de mieux connaître et et
pour nous-même de nous enrichir sur des
collections mais également avoir une une
une quelque chose de de de plus large
nous avons donc sommes donc saisis d'une
des
principales missions de collecte et de
recherche qui a été mené en 1931 à 1933
qui est partie de Dakar et qui est allé
jusqu'à djibou outil et nous avons
constitué un programme de recherche avec
l'ensemble des partenaires l'ensemble
des pays qui constituent cette cette
diagonale il est bien évident
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons dû moduler
notre enthousiasme du début puisqueun
certain nombre de de de pays sont
aujourd'hui et de régions sont
aujourd'hui impossible à à à rejoindre
l'idée c'était de confronter finalement
cette histoire ancienne la la
l'préhension que nous pouvons en avoir
depuis depuis l'Europe avec
l'appréhension qui pouvait en être faite
depuis ces différents pays donc donc le
ça concerne les pays que j'ai cité mais
également Djibouti mais également le
Cameroun mais également le Sénégal
évidemment la la la la Côte d'Ivoire
donc c'est un travail de longue haleine
qui verra son aboutissement dans un
premier temps par une exposition qui
aura lie au musée du kbranli en 2025 et
qui ensuite sera décliné dans les
différents pays qui auront la la la
volonté de le faire selon des modalités
qui ne seront pas une exposition pensée
à Paris et envoyé en Afrique mais une
adaptation une reformulation une
réinvention finalement de euh cette de
de de de de cette exposition en fonction
des intérêts propres de chaque pays on
voit bien même sur ce travail qui semble
euh relativement homogène qui nous faut
nous adapter à chaque fois à des
perceptions à des sensibilité et infra à
l'intérieur de chaque pays aussi il y a
des des relations inter
intercommunautaires qui sont extrêmement
complexes qui sont évolutive et dont il
nous faut absolument euh tenir compte
nous travaillons évidemment de manière
très étroite avec la Côte d'Ivoire
puisque bientôt sera présenté devant
devant l'Assemblée nationale le le le le
projet de loi sur les sur sur les
rtitutions et la Côte d'Ivoire nous
avons pour la Côte d'Ivoire nous avons
nous avons travaillé en particulier sur
un un projet qui leur tient à cœur et
qui remplit jusqu'à présent les
différents critères qui avaient été
retenus pour des des
restitutions pour faire en sorte que ces
restitutions ne soient pas simplement un
un un geste certes important mais qui
finalement se s'achève avec le le le
fait de de de de du retour de l'objet
nous travaillons également la mise en
œuvre de de collaboration pour
accompagner ce processus politique de
restitution qui vise à à à à partager
l'information professionnelle que nous
avons et de faire en sorte que nos nos
propres agents mais aussi les agents des
différents musées concernés et euh
puissent travailler en bonne
intelligence pour pour le futur c'est
particulièrement le cas pour le musée
historique d'abomé et le Musée
d'histoire de wiida au Bénin qui ont été
décidé suite à la la restitution des 26
œuvres des des des collections
nationales françaises en direction de la
République du Bénin et c'est également
le le cas avec la le musée d'isation de
Côte d'Ivoire avec lequel nous
travaillons en préparation à ce qui
pourrait donner lieu à une restitution
si tel en était la volonté nationale
nous travaillons également à la à la
formation des futurs de nos futurs
collègues conservateurs et restaurateurs
du du du patrimoine et ceci en
collaboration avec les instituts de
formation l'Institut national de de de
du patrimoine avec l'École du Louvre et
nous accueillons pour des stages souvent
de de longue durée ces différents futurs
collègues nous avons travailler avec le
le le le Gabon de de personnes du Gabon
avec une personne de du du Bénin évid
avec une personne de des Commores et une
personne de de Côte d'Ivoire et nous
continuons à accueillir très
régulièrement chaque
année c'est ces personnels j'en profite
pour souligner d'ailleurs que le nous
accueillons actuellement le musée le le
directeur du Musée national du du du de
Côte d'Ivoire nous participons
évidemment à des formations n nos
professionnels participent à des
formation je voudrais pour finir
insister sur le fait que il nous semble
important de créer les condition aussi
d'une circulation des œuvres puisque
c'était aussi la l'idée de de de du
discours de de Dakar et donc nous avons
organisé avec les collègues européens à
Dakar au début de cette année une grande
réunion avec une soixantaine de musées
africains pour essayer de définir quel
pourrait être leur besoin et comment
faire en sorte de travailler en dehors
de nos relations historiques limitées
avec les les les pays autrefois colonisé
par la France et élargir et nous avons
présenté à la Commission européenne un
projet assez ambitieux visant à euh
faire en sorte de collaborer de manière
plus large entre une collaboration plus
large entre la France et et via l'Europe
et les pays africains bien merci à tous
les deux pour ces propos introductifs
mes chers collègues il nous reste une
vingtaine de minutes j'ai environ se
questions donc l'idéal serait que chacun
se limite à une question de l'ordre de
une minute ou un peu plus pour qu'on ait
2 xis 5 minutes pour pour les réponses
et vous parliez monsieur le président de
Côte d'Ivoire ben j'ai le plaisir de
passer la parole à une collègue qui est
né en Côte d'Ivoire pour le groupe
Renaissance la parole est à Lisianne
mteayer merci monsieur le Président
merci madame la Présidente donc
respectectivement des commissions et
délégations monsieur le Président du
musée du cabbran lit madame la
Présidente alors c'est un honneur
effectivement pour moi de de prendre la
parole effectivement comme la stipulé le
Président je suis effectivement né en
Côte d'Ivoire j'ai vécu en Côte d'Ivoire
et j'avais vraiment une oreille
extrêmement attentive en fait sur vos
propos et je serais très intéressée en
fait pour évoquer un peu plus avant en
fait ce ces restitutions
au nom du groupe Renaissance je vous
remercie sincèrement pour votre
participation au sein de nos commissions
et délégations conjointes ainsi que pour
la qualité de de vos interventions vos
contributions de ce jour abordé sous
l'angle culturel et médiatique en
rchissent significativement nos travaux
en cours consacrés à l'Afrique en
introduction il convient de rappeler
qu'au moment de son élection en 2017 le
président de la République français a
exprimé son engagement à revitaliser les
liens entre la France et le continent
africain cette démarche est concrétisée
par diverses initiatives mettant
particulièrement l'accent sur la
refondte de notre aide en faveur d'une
relation
partenariale je peux citer les les
dialogues afrique- France conduit par
achil Mbembé philosophe africain mais
également le nouvel sommet et également
le nouveau sommet afrique-fance cette
refonte du partenariat de la France avec
les pay du continent africain est bâti
autour de la société civile et du
soutien au secteur privé et offre un
nouveau cadre de réflexion aux nouvelles
générations de la relation entre
l'Afrique et la
France dans le domaine de la culture
cette refonte est mise en œuvre très
concrètement notamment ici en France et
à Paris et dernièrement et j'aimerais
profiter de votre présence parmi nous
pour évoquer le forum de création Africa
qui s'est déroulé donc en octobre
dernier il s'agit du premier salon de ce
type en Europe autour des industries
culturelles et créatives et qui se
déroulera de de façon alternative entre
la France et les pays du continent
africain ces industries culturelles et
créatives englobent les secteurs liés à
la création au développement à la
production et à la diffusion de biens de
servic et d'activités à contenu culturel
artistique et ou patrimonial à la
croisée des diplomaties économique et
d'influence la promotion des industries
culturelles et créative est un élément
clé de la politique française pour
revenir à cette première édition de
création Africa dans la lignée du
nouveau sommet afrique- France comme je
viens de l'évoquer ce forum vise à
encourager la création de passerell
créative et le partage d'idées
innovantes dans la France et les pays du
continent africain ce forum a pour
ambition de devenir le rendez-vous
incontournaable des créateurs ces
initiatives contribuent à renforcer les
liens entre les individus en favorisant
un échange interculturelle dynamique je
vais aller plus vite donc pour reprendre
juste quelques chiffres hein c'était
quand même 400 participants dans 200
personnes provenant du continent
africain aussi je souhaiterais vous
poser deux questions est-ce que la mise
en avant de nos cultures respectives
constitue un des moyens approprié pour
approfondir la compréhension entre nos
peuples et redéfinir la relation entre
l'Afrique et la France quelle est votre
perception de ce genre d'initiative axé
sur la promotion d'une approche
partenariale je vous remercie merci pour
le groupe rassemblement national la
parole est à Giselle
lelouis présidente madame monsieur mes
chers collègues en tant qu'élu de
Marseille je suis ravi de vous entendre
ce matin aux auditions car ma ville la
plus ancienne de France est un lieu où
les cultures dialogent pour reprendre
une devise du musé quebranl c'est c'est
sur ce dialogue culturel au-delà des
présentations très intéressante que vous
faites que vous avez fait que j'aimerais
centrer mon propos en tant que membre de
la commission de la défense je ne peux
que déplorer leséerement de la politique
française actuelle en Afrique qui
conduisent à une telle hostilité et
incompréhension dans certains pays que
les troupes françaises sont contraintes
de se retirer dans la précipitation à
l'inverse la coopération culturelle
offre des perspectives d'avenir
encourageantes en atteste au l'audience
de France medéia monde en Afrique fRANCE
24 est assi la première chaîne
d'information en Afrique francophone
avec 400 millions de téléspectateurs
hebdomadaires RFI compte pour sa part 38
millions d'auditeurs hebdomadaires nous
nous en réjouissons même si nous uront
l'écho parfois donné à des discours
antifrançais ou plus récemment
anti-israéliens les restitutions de
certaines œuvres sont également vu comme
un élément d'apaisement des relations le
groupe rassemblement national est
d'ailleurs favorable à des restitution
au cas par cas si ce n'est pas question
de vider les collections nationales nous
considérons que certaines restitutions
participe au maintien du dialogue
culturel si précieux que j'évoquais en
préambule nous sommes tout aussi
convaincu que la conservation la
restauration et la présentation d'œuvres
sur notre sol au kbranl par exemple
permettent une connaissance et une
protection du très riche et très divers
patrimoine africain à destination du
public du monde entier sur le plan de
cette protection j'auris justement une
question quant au patrimoine malien lors
des raides d'ACMI notamment sur tomuktu
en 2013 des témoignages exceptionnels du
passé ont été détruits ou partiellement
détruits par les terroristes islamistes
avez-vous des éléments quant à la
restauration de ce patrimoine
exceptionnel sur le plan de la langue
française nous savons que des pays
étrangers comme la Russie la Chine ou la
Turquie déploi leurs médias en Afrique
avec un discours parfois hostile à la
France pouvez-vous nous en dire plus sur
leur pénétration du paysage audiovisuel
notamment en Afrique francophone je vous
remercie merci pour le groupe la France
insoumise la parole est à Pascal ban
merci monsieur le Président du fait de
l'héritage colonial français sur le
continent africain la coopération entre
l'Afrique et la France est
particulièrement riche elle l' d'autant
plus ces derniers temps avec la volonté
en tout cas affiché de la France de
démocratiser sa relation avec ses
partenaires africains de nombreux forums
culturels participent notamment et vous
l'avez rappelé au rayonnement de la
culture française en Afrique et au
rayonnement des cultures d'Afrique en
France cette politique culturelle de la
même manière qu'elle s'inscrit dans un
contexte historique chargé s'avère
souvent un levier de puissance et de
politique étrangère pour la France en
témoigne plusieurs décisions et
déclarations françaises la plus récente
concerne la cacophonie autour de la
suspension je cite de tous les projets
de coopération qui sont menés avec des
institutions ou des ressortissants et
ressortissantes du Burkina Faso du Mali
et du Niger puis la déclaration de la
ministre Rima abdoumak qui déclarait je
cite encore qu'aucune des programmations
d'artistes n'avait été demandé par le
gouvernement la France a siamment mis un
coup d'arrêt à la la coopération
culturelle avec ces états en tâchant de
fait le dialogue interculturel entre les
peuples concernés aussi plusieurs
articles universitaire et de presse
dénonce le fait que le musée du kbranly
ne traite que trop peu voire pas de la
question de l'héritage colonial de la
France en Afrique alors que cela
pourrait être fait à la fois à travers
l'art et l'ethnologie ne serait-ce pas
un moyen pour renforcer voir relancer le
dialogue interculturel avec l'Afrique il
pourrait également être intéressant de
savoir comment est perçu dans milieu
culturel français l'émancipation des
artistes et des intellectuels et
universitaires africains ainsi que la
dénonciation croissante d'une certaine
politique néopatrimoniale menée par la
France quelle est votre perception de la
politique française de suspension des
visas y compris pour les artistes quelle
retombée à ce stade cette décision ne
risque-t-elle pas d'entacher le dialogue
interculturel entre les peuples
d'Afrique et de France et les
perceptions de ces peuples dans leur
culture je vous remercie merci pour le
groupe démocrate la parole est à Vincent
Bru merci monsieur le Président pour
madame Cécile mie pour aller plus vite
vous avez évoqué à plusieurs reprises la
la censure dont nous avons été l'objet
de la part des autorités nigériennes et
en précédemment au Mali et au burgina
Faso ma ma ma question est la suivante
est-ce que les dirigeants africains vous
ont donné des des motivations de de ces
décision où ont donné des motivations au
gouvernement français d'autre part
est-ce que cette politique de censure
touche la France uniquement ou d'autres
pays européens ou occidentaux et puis
vous avez parlé de de chaînes qui sont
pas toujours très très amicales vis-àvis
de notre
pays venant de la Turquie de la Russie
qu'en est-il par exemple de la Chine
pour Monsieur
kererou une petite question simplement
j'aimerais avoir un petit peu plus de
détails sur l'accompagnement de la
France et particulièrement de votre
musée pour assurer des conditions
nécessaires à la réception et à la la
conservation des œuvres qui sont
restituées dans les pays africains je
vous remercie merci chers collègues et
merci de votre esprit de synthèse pour
le groupe socialiste la parole est à
Isabelle Santiago
oui je vais je vais donc faire cours
aussi comme c'est demandé
donc ma question s'adressera du coup à
tous les trois au travers de des
échanges que nous avons extrêmement
intéressants vous avez pu nous éclairer
ce matin est-ce que vous pourriez nous
dire compte tenu des enjeux et compris
de pouvoir être en partage sur ces
territoires est-ce que vous avez les
moyens et c'est intéressant pour nous de
le savoir en tant que parlementaire pour
irriguer les travaux au travers de
l'ensemble y compris évidemment sur le
musée donc évidemment au cbranl où j'ai
évidemment eu très avec beaucoup
d'intérêt ce que vous nous avez exposé
mais ça nécessite beaucoup d'échanges
beaucoup de recherches la rest
institution qui se fait comme vous nous
l'avez expliqué sur un travail en
partage sur les œuvres sur cette culture
qui évidemment entre les peuples est un
pont et une richesse donc avoir une idée
euh y compris sur le réseau évidemment
de culturel queon puisse avoir cette
vision qui est très transversale à
travers vos vos trois à propos euh si
vous en avez les moyens contenu qu'on
qu'on bascule sur une autre prise de on
va dire pas de risque mais d'engagement
auprès d'eux il ne faudrait pas
décevoir merci nous avons trois
questions complémentaires la parole est
à Delphine
ingeman merci monsieur le Président euh
je ma question s'adresserait à Madame
madame mie euh plus de la moitié en fait
de de la population africaine étagé de
moins de de 24 ans on assiste également
vous l'avez souligné à une montée en
puissance des réseaux sociaux dans la
diffusion de vos programmes vous avez
parlé de WhatsApp et de Youtube je
voudrais moi vous parler de TikTok qui
est le navire amiral de du soft power
chinois euh il a dépassé dans nombreux
pays africains il me semble les réseaux
sociaux dit traditionnels euh notamment
en Afrique subsaharienne puisqu'il
arrive en 2e position je voudrais savoir
quelle place vous accordez à TikTok dans
votre stratégie de déploiement sur le
continent africain et par ailleurs en ce
qui concerne les réseaux sociaux euh en
prévention de ou ou en sensibilisation
par rapport au fake news est-ce que vous
intervenez est-ce que vous participez à
des programmes de sensibilisation auprès
des jeunes sur le continent africain
merci merci la parole est à jean-filippe
Ardoin merci monsieur le Président pour
Madame la la directrice dans plusieurs
conflits civils touchant des pays
africains la France en tant qu'ex
puissance colonial est souvent pointé du
doigt accusé de nombreux mots que l'on
évoque le Mali en 2022 où le bourg
nafasso en 2023 ce constat de Roger de
la France s'inscrit également dans une
Hut d'influence informationnelle menée
par la Russie et la Chine le 3 mai 2023
reporter sans frontière a souligné la
désinformation en hausse et les menaces
envers les journalistes dans de nombreux
pays africain RFI et France 24 ont
notamment été suspendus au Mali en avril
2022 pour des raisons politiques qui
relève d'une évidente atteinte à la
liberté de la presse aussi comment
conciliez-vous votre statut de médias
indép avec l'image média français qui
vous a renvoyé lecalement et quelles en
sont les conséquences notamment sur
votre ligne éditoriale et d'autre part
comment assurez-vous la sécurité de vos
correspondants dans les pays qui
traversent ces troubles je vous remercie
merci enfin la parole est à Christophe
Marion merci monsieur le Président de de
m'accueillir exceptionnellement dans
votre commission monsieur le Président
j'ai eu le plaisir d'échanger avec vous
il y a quelques semaines dans le cadre
de la proposition de loi relative à la
restitution des restes humains
appartenant aux collection publique il
me semble que ce sujet est un enjeu
culturel et diplomatique important de la
relation entre les pays étrangers
notamment africains et la France en
effet cette proposition de loi devrait
permettre de répondre aux demandes de
restitution formulées notamment par
l'Australie l'Argentine ou Madagascar
l'Afrique n'est pas particulièrement
représenter ce qui peut sembler étonnant
au regard du passé colonial de notre
nation comment expliquez-vous cette
situation pensez-vous à partir de vos
connaissances et des coopérations que
vous menez avec les musées du continent
africain que des demandes de restitution
sont à venir
ou que la France devrait communiquer
davantage sur ses capacités de
restitution auprès des pays africains je
crois me souvenir que en tant que
directeur du Centre Culturel jbaou vous
aviez décidé après discussion avec les
anciens de laisser des restes Canac au
musée de San Francisco où ils étaient
conservé si une telle décision était
prise par un État africain dans les
prochaines années comment
envisageriez-vous les conditions
d'exposition de ces restes humains dans
nos musée pour en faire de véritables
ambassadeurs culturels de leur pays
d'origine je vous remercie merci à tous
pour vos questions madame monsieurs je
vous propose alors malheureusement de
limiter vos réponses à 5 minutes chacun
en choisissant les éléments qui vous
semble les les plus essentiels pour
qu'on ait pas trop de retard pour
l'audition suivante madame vous avez la
parole merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président oui difficile de répondre en 5
minutes à la diversité de vos de vos
questions qui mériterait quand même
d'être enfin les réponses mériteraient
d'être très
précises un un premier un premier point
concernant les initiatives madame vous
évoqueiez le le forum création Africa
les partenariats je pense que là
vraiment ça s'inscrit dans ces
initiatives auxquelles nous donnons de
l'écho depuis Paris vers le continent
africain et pour lequ pour lesquels nous
nous regardons aussi en très grande
proximité grâce à notre réseau de
correspondant grâce à nos nos envoyés
spéciaux quel est l'effet sur le
continent africain et je pense que c'est
c'est cet aller-retour euh qui n'est pas
euh dans un sens unique je pense que
c'est vraiment le cette cette image de
l'aller-retour entre la France et le
continent qui est évoqué sur nos
antennes je pourrais être vous donner
des listes euh sans fin de de programmes
qui sont consacrés de reportage de voilà
qui qui qui fait la le le lien et qui
maintient ce lien malgré le contexte que
nous avons tous décrit que vous vous
avez également repris dans vos propos
euh de de tension à certains endroits et
à certains moments euh ce lien est
essentiel à maintenir et comment
maintenons-nous ce lien donc à travers
ce type d'initiative la valorisation de
de de de l'ensemble de ces ces ces
manifestations qui ont lieu sur le
continent ou en France en France ou sur
le continent mais également euh je pense
en restant euh conforme euh cohérent et
et fidèle à ce qui fait euh les valeurs
et les principes éthiques déontologiques
d'un média de service public d'un pays
démocratique qui s'appelle 'aelle la
France c'està-dire que nous avons un
arsenal de texte alors la loi bien sûr
mais nous avons aussi en interne une
charte de déontologie un cahier des
charges une charge de déontologie que
nous nous nous faisons également
prospérer au vu des évolutions de
l'intelligence artificielle et comment
l'utiliser ou comment s'en prémunir que
nous faisons nous nous sommes soumis
évidemment à la loi Sapin 2 donc nous
avons des programmes de formation et de
sensibilisation de nos nos personnes y
compris des journalistes bien entendu
donc tout ce
dispositif éthique et déontologique est
pour nous la pierre angulaire de notre
travail et nous sommes persuadés
aujourd'hui que rester dans C dans cette
ligne là sans compromission sans sans en
sans en dévier et pour nous une façon de
rester fidèle à ce que doit être un
média libre et indépendant comme l'avait
rappelé le président de la République
devant les ambassadeurs pas naïf pas
naïf nous sommes bien conscients que
nous sommes directement attaqués parce
que nous sommes un média de service
public français non pas un média d'État
et que notre indépendance est en quelque
sorte notre influence aussi et que de
fait en restant fidèle à ces principesl
nous pensons pouvoir répondre au défi
qui est le notre aujourd'hui et qui qui
qui que que vous décrivez parfaitement
qui est celui de rester résilient mais
démocratique dans un dans un contexte de
plus en plus difficile et tendu sur la
question des moyens nous avons eu les
arbitrages budgétaires pour la l'année
2024 en matière de moyens il y a un
signe extérieur d'indépendance qui est
la recette affectée et qui pour nous
dans notre arsenal de voilà comment
prouver que la France se dote de médias
de servicees publics indépendants et
quelque chose d'extrêmement important
Marie-Christine saragos a l'habitude
d'insisterer sur ce point et je pense
que c'est c'est vraiment
essentiel nous avons eu une dotation euh
en hausse euh même s'il y a des effets
d'optique comp tenu du du changement de
de modalité de financement et maintenant
lié à la TVA et non plus à la la la CAP
mais euh nous restons quand même avec
des budgets en desessà de nos
partenaires et amis du des services
publics internationaux que sont la BBC
et la Deutsch chevel par exemple alors
que nos performances dans nos dans notre
périmètre de d'Afrique francophone par
exemple sont bien supérieures à celles
de la BBC en Afrique anglophone donc
voilà euh très sommairement plus serait
mieux avec ce que nous avons aujourd'hui
nous pouvons développer encore des
programmes mais nous sommes bien
conscients qu'il y a quand même et et
nous avons subi pendant plusieurs années
euh des des régulations successives nous
sommes quand même en retrait euh par
rapport à nos partenaires que sont BBC
World Service ou la la Deutsche V sans
parler euh de USA global media le le
service extérieur de des des médias
publics américains euh TikTok les
réseaux sociaux donc l'objc et ça
rejoint aussi les moyens euh bien sûr
que nous sommes conscients que c'est un
vecteur extrêmement important et
notamment pour toucher les jeunes
publics WhatsApp en est un aussi et
WhatsApp est un terrain de de de
prolifération d'un Fox mais considérable
donc le fait que l'opérateur MTA
permette aujourd'hui au médias de de
d'arriver sur WhatsApp nous a permis de
rentrer dans le dans la dans la boucle
très rapidement nous l'avions initié il
y a quelques années pour RFI et MTA à
coupé donc on s'est on s'est retiré sur
TikTok nous France 24 euh a commencé à
se se se se développer sur TikTok nous
avons des projets pour RFI également
reste que c'est des questions de moyens
parce que la grammère en quelque sorte
le terme de jargon peut-être qui est
utilisée la grammaire pour s'adresser à
ces publics là et pour s'exprimer en
quelque sorte sur TikTok n'est
absolument pas la même que celle qu'on a
sur le broadcast pour France24 sur
WhatsApp ou sur ou sur sur X donc ou sur
sans compter Facebook donc aujourd'hui
ça veut dire des personnels
supplémentaires ça veut dire un
apprentissage supplémentaire donc là
nous travaillons à pouvoir y y être y
être présent mais nous sommes bien
conscients que c'est quelque chose de
primordial et quand je parlais de ce
projet 100 % numérique à destination des
jeunes publics Afric des jeunes publics
du continent africain c'est sur les
réseaux sociaux et on est en train
d'étudier plus précisément la
configuration que ça aura ce sera de la
vidéo et ce sera sans doute sur TikTok
mais aussi sur Youtube enfin voilà les
les les champs sont extrêmement vastes
et et nous devons évidemment s'adresser
au plus de public possi sur les les
plateformes les les plus diverses
possibles je n'ai absolument pas répondu
à toutes les questions mais le temps
imparti estc merci Madame pour ses
réponses c'est désolé pour le caractère
très contraint du temps dont nous
disposons la parole est au président
Kazar
rou merci monsieur le Président oui je
essayer aussi de répondre alors sur les
les partenariats la création
effectivement nous nous nous abandons
dans ce sens c'estàd que on pense que
c'est c'est par une construction commune
une coconstruction en fait et un regard
commun porté sur le passé qui peut être
divergent d'ailleurs hein mais qu'on
peut construire quelque chose de durable
et en et en toute vérité en toute
transparence le vous avez insisté aussi
sur la création on a pas parlé le musée
c'est aussi c'est le passé mais c'est
aussi le présent et la création
contemporaine je pense que les demandes
sont aussi
an dans ce domaine il y a une manière de
et je pense c'est une manière différente
aussi de regarder l'Afrique que de
laavir au travers de ses créateurs vous
parler de de créateurs dans des domaines
numériques mais il y a aussi les les les
créateurs les peintres d'aujourd'hui il
y a il y a un marché de de de l'art
africain contemporain qui est en train
de se développer et c'est une manière
totalement différente de d'entrer en
relation et d'accompagner cette relation
que nous nous appelons nos vœux avec le
avec l'Afrique je vis signaler aussi que
en matière de musée il n'y a pas les
musées africains nont pas forcément
vocation à ne s'intéresser qu'à
l'Afrique nous avons nous-même à la
demande de
nos de nos collègues sénégalais
organiser une une exposition Picasso et
lesarts africains à Dakar qui était une
première ça s'est pas fait depuis 1966
et et je pense que c'est quelque chose
aussi dans lequel nous devons aller
c'estàdire que nous devons connaître les
lieux d'où nous parlons être fiers de
nos héritages en même temps pouvoir les
les les confronter de manière plus
apaisée en sachant exactement de quel
point on on part et la manière dont nous
pouvons les partager sur la question des
destructions évidemment il y a a il y a
cette menace permanente sur la
destruction du du patrimoine
malheureusement je nen sais pas plus il
farait demander à mes collègues qui
travaillent à laal ce qui est sur sur
ces menaces en tout cas nous en sommes
bien bien conscients d'où le travail que
nous faisons avec par exemple le
collègue du Musée National du Mali
c'estd d'identifier des collections qui
si elle retournait ne serait pas soumise
à une pression telle qui les appellerait
qui appellerit à leur destruction donc
c'est aussi je pense qu'il en est
absolument bien conscient nous aussi et
donc il y a une il y a une sorte de
relation d'intelligence qui se noue
entre nous sur ces questions euh sur la
question de l'héritage colonial c'est
vrai que c'est quelque chose d'assez euh
euh que sur laquelle nous essayons de
travailler également avec toute la
complexité que ça représente parce que
souvent nous n'avons qu'une qu'une
qu'une partie de la de de de de la de de
la source n avons que des documents qui
vont dans un sens et les les le le
travail sur les sur le le sur l'histoire
coloniale mérite là aussi une double
lecture une au moins une multi une une
lecture multivocale il y a aussi des
ressentis qui ne pas n'apparaissent pas
dans nos sources il y a aussi des des
des imprégnations mémoriales très fortes
qu'on ne perçoit pas forcément au
travers de l'étude simplement
scientifique qu'on peut en avoir
historique de de de notre côté et donc
il y a il y a un travail commun à faire
je pense c'est un travail qui peut se
faire sur le moyen long terme d'où le le
projet que nous dont je parlais tout à
l'heure de Dakar Djibouti qui consiste
aussi à regarder les conditions
d'acquisition de collection et de
recherche également parce que toute
cette connaissance est du aussi à ces
recherches qui sont faites en période
coloniale d'étudier toutes les les
tenant aboutissant de cette de de ces de
ces
contextes en ce qui concerne
l'accompagnement que nous faisons au aux
différents musées et aux différents
collègues il s'agit aussi j'ai j'ai j'ai
j'ai
mentionné les les les les les transferts
aussi de documents qui sont très
importants il y a souvent une sous
représentation de la documentation dans
ces dans dans dans les musées avec
lesquels nous travaillons du fait de des
visitudes de de l'histoire comme
nous-même nous les avons nous nous les
subissons parfois et donc il y a il y a
il y a il y a un important travail de
partage de de de ces documents et de
mise en en en en en commun de ces
documents cette expertise que que l'on
essaie de de porter elle se fait aussi
de manière très modeste c'est-à-dire que
on on attend qu'on nous demande vraiment
de de que le que le besoin s'exprime et
on évite de de d'arriver avec ce qu'on
pense être bon l'idée c'est vraiment
c'est d'inverser la la la la la la la la
dimension et et de susciter l'émergence
du besoin pour pouvoir mieux y répondre
et euh et ainsi avoir une une une
relation de nature différente sur les
moyens nécessaires évidemment nous
travaillons à moyen constant et nous
essayons effectivement de de de re
réorienter une partie de de nos besoins
de nos de nos ressources le musée c'est
à la fois un département des collections
mais c'est aussi un département de la
recherche avec lequel nous travaillons
nous avons cette double tutelle la
chance d'avoir cette double tutelle à la
fois de la culture et Ministère de la
Recherche et lenseignement supérieur et
une grande partie de nos moyens de
recherche ont été
re réorientés vers ces questions ces
questions d'histoire coloniale ces
questions parce que pour éclairer les
restitutions il faut aussi éclairer
l'histoire coloniale je disais que notre
notre la manière dont on réalisait à
quel point on la méconnaissait dans son
détail et dans la manière dont elles ont
pu affecter les populations donc il y a
un gros travail à faire dans dans ce
domaine je me réjoui d'ailleurs de
l'annonce de la ministre de la Culture
qui qui a présenté une un fond commun
Germano français qui va permettre de
financer aussi des des des questions de
ces questions de de provenance c'est un
travail long fastidieux dans lequel nous
engageons et dans laquelle il faut que
nous engageons de manière commune à la
fois avec les partenaires européens
parce que cette cette histoire
européenne elle est pas c histoire
française elle est pas que française
elle est européenne les informations
sont souvent diffus sont son sont
appartiennent à d'autres à d'autres pays
nous faut les concentrer et en même
temps faire ce travail que j'évoqué tout
à l'heure avec les les les pays
d'origine en ce qui concerne les les
restes humains je pense que nous avons
effectivement besoin de de continuer à
faire ce travail proactif que nous avons
réalisé il faut pas attendre que les les
les les la demande arrive il faut qu'on
soit en capacité de répondre le plus
clairement possible avec les éléments
les plus objectifs possibles historiques
sur sur ces demandes comme nous le
faisons exactement pour les objets c'est
aussi ce gros travail que nous faisons
c'est pas répondre simplement aux
demandes c'est anticiper dans les
collections avec les critères que l'on a
arrêté cette question de est-ce que ces
collections sont arrivé de manière
légitime ou pas et quelles sont les
circonstances historiques qui permettent
d'éclairer l'arrivée de ces collections
euh en en dans dans les biens de de de
la nation j'ajouterai pour terminer que
nous faisons aussi un important travail
de désanomyisation euh des personnes qui
ont été photographiées en en en en
contexte colonial il y a un un gros
travail à faire souvent euh l'époque
voulait qu'on enlève l'information
singulière et personnelle pour la
remplacer par une information générique
de type humain de de et il y a un gros
travail à faire parce que nous disposons
en fait souvent de l' de l'information
euh personnelle concernant les individus
photographiés et il y a un travail qui a
été engagé par le musée du kbranli et
qui en particulier sur la question pour
revenir avec la question des des restes
humains euh illustre le le la question
des guyanis qui fait partie des demandes
de de du département de la Guyane en
direction de ces personnes qui ont été
exhibées en et qui sont mortes en France
nous avons avec un travail commun avec
l'association guyanaise qui porte cette
mémoire c'estit un travail de de de
retrouver les individus photographiés et
de leur mettre des noms je pense c'est
c'est un domaine très important
excusez-moi monsieur le Président merci
infiniment à nos deux invités pour leur
éclairage et je vais essayer d'être très
bre pour cette
conclusion j'ai été témoin et très
heureux témoins de cette cocréation et
coconstruction muséale avec votre
exposition la route des che je du
Cameroun qui a été exposé d'abord au
Cameroun puis au musée du kéenli qui a
eu un succès le succès que nous
connaissons tous pour la notoriété
Cécile mi effectivement je me rends tous
les mois quasiment dans les pays
africains et et et elle est illustrer et
et je voudrais saluer votre collègue
julette fé et son émission légendes
urbaines tous les jeunes Maliens que je
connais burkinabé ou nigérien utilise
des VPN pour regarder son émission donc
effectivement vous avez entièrement
raison et je ne peux pas clôturer
conclure pardon cette table ronde sans
corriger une infox que je trouve être
une infox non les Herm de la France ce
que je ne peux pas consider comme des
Herms bien sûr ne sont pas ne sont
pas la la cause du retrait de Barkan la
France n'est pas responsable de PCH de
militaire antidémocratique donc ce n'est
absolument pas à cause de la France que
barcan a quitté le Sahel et enfin en
tout cas le Mali et le Niger merci et
j'ai envie de dire si on continue dans
sur ce terrain là le Québec est une
ancienne colonie française et le Québec
n'utilise pas la France comme Bou
émissaire à chaque mot intern du pays
merci bien ben écoutez la séance est
suspendue on se retrouve tout de suite
pour une nouvelle séance à à
HCl